josh is with us in Indianapolis hey Josh
how are you good sir how about you
better than I deserve what's up well I
have a quick question about a we always
haven't we have a credit one credit card
being my wife and we always pay it every
month we use it just for you know
general expenses and we earn cash back
on this credit card every you know every
month or whatever we can turn in for
cash I was wondering if you think it's
still a good idea to have this credit
card even you know even though you don't
like credit cards no I wouldn't have it
you wouldn't have it even though you are
in cash back no how much cash back have
you earned
I usually average about four hundred
dollars a year Wow
changing your life isn't it well I mean
you know we've been putting it into my
daughter's savings account for dude
you're having a discussion with you over
$400 a year really all I'm just asking
to see you know I mean because we always
pay it off but you strongly suggest
against having credit cards and I
wouldn't have one here's the thing the
to start with I have a debit card it
does everything yours does except the
400 bucks so paying it off is paying it
off right and and secondly this
discussion is not going to bankrupt you
and so you're probably not the guy who's
going to call me up with $48,000 in
credit card debt that I get to talk to
every day and that's not you you're not
that guy you're your control you're
disciplined you're smart with money and
those kinds of things what you've missed
out on though is this that personal
finance is 80 percent behavior and 20
percent head knowledge credit card
companies know this at some point the
average person playing your game ends up
with a credit card balance they don't
man they're not managed to do it now you
may be the one guy out of however how
many that doesn't and so then the
philosophical discussion continues the
biggest problem you've got though is
this you're spending a lot of effort
chasing 400 bucks and it's actually
implanted into your mind and what all
the studies are showing us is that when
that's happening that you spend more on
plastic than you do with cash an example
is at the grocery store the average
person using plastic including a debit
card okay but versus actual
hundred-dollar bills the hundred dollar
bills equate to pain
it activates the pain centers in the
brain and so when you're standing in the
grocery store line and you lay three
$100 bills and Uncle Ben is smiling up
at you on the counter your emotions have
an ouchy moment and if you know that's
coming when you get there because that's
your normal pattern you will spend on
average 22% less in the grocery store
ah and so that's what that four hundred
dollars cost you is you tend to on
little things impulse and the smaller it
is the more the percentages go berserk
like here's another you know if you have
you never been the hotel lately where
now they're taking credit cards for the
vending machine oh yeah I've seen them
I've never used them now yeah that blew
my mind the first time I thought
somebody putting a bag of potato chips
on a freaking credit card but but here's
the interesting thing you know why
they're doing it is they're finding
their sales are up a hundred and seventy
eight percent oh yeah more convenient
they're almost tripling their sales know
its impulse well yeah because instead of
putting a dollar in there and it spits
it back out three times and I can't get
it to take the stupid dollar right
instead of doing that I pop it in there
and I go well it's on the card I'll just
get chips and I'll get M&Ms and I'll get
a coke you know and then you just load
the thing up and again it's not enough
to make you go broke but what happens is
that's an indication of we spend more
when we use plastic so given that you
and I are on the same page in that we do
wouldn't ever want to carry a balance
the debit card is the safest way to do
that and it keeps you from slipping into
hey I'm chasing I'm going to spend
$4,000 chasing 400 and if you're not
real careful you can get there so that
that's you know it's a real logical
thing it's not that I'm just some kind
of whacked-out fanatic although I am but
there's real logic behind it so that's
why I don't believe in credit cards at
all I don't see any reason for them and
you know I've met with thousands of
millionaires over the years of me doing
this I've never met a millionaire said
Dave you know I made it all with that
cash back it's what my breakthrough was
it was very line miles man put me over
the top changed my life finaiiy I was
transformed now they don't say that let
me never say that